what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a clip that's going
around again and it's where a woman
demanded a 200 000 engagement ring on my
channel before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel if you have
watched three or more of my videos and
you don't subscribe we have beef people
beef
i'm serious okay okay
um so what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
tell you
what was going on in this and what i
wish i said because there's some things
that i didn't say that i wish i did yeah
sometimes you're caught off guard
okay that sort of sort of space
back he's he's immediately like i'm
gonna let's celebrate like i want to
take you out and i'm like oh
how many how many dates have you guys
gone on one okay yeah we went on one
right before i left that was our first
first date this is a date
go ahead sorry so now we'll go i guess
on the second one
wonder if he's kind of um it's only like
five nine i wonder if they actually went
on a second one
oh that's you're you're what like five
i'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really
you know manifesting a tall man one of
the other guys i'm talking to is six
foot seven
oh wow
yeah okay
my thought during this was
six seven okay
don't get me wrong i love me
a tall guy six three
six four six five six six six seven
don't get me wrong but ladies
we gotta be realistic
the guy that's six seven is talking to
like five other girls if he's if he's
good looking okay
so my thought was is how interested is
this man really but they hadn't even met
i was like what on earth
what on earth
okay
um and we'll be going out soon it's just
a matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like link on the
schedules we both work a lot
if a guy likes you he'll figure out
how to make his schedule work
like i'm just saying
there's another guy who i just made this
whole take a tick tock about who
was like all about me asking me out
calling me all these pet names my love
and all this [ __ ] and then we're talking
and i was like oh you have the vaccine
right and he was like no
i was like you're not vaccinated and you
want to go out with me i'm like i'm not
going out with you you're not vaccinated
what are you [ __ ] me kissing you
you're not vaccinated i'm like
really oh i wouldn't care i don't care
in too many arenas where you have to be
vaccinated like i work at a yoga studio
where we're requiring proof of
vaccination that's where i am right now
holding all the surgery and all these
music festivals where they're requiring
proof of vaccination and to me it's so
much deeper than just like do you or
don't you it's about that like i don't
want to have that debate with you right
like clearly
if we don't view it the same way we're
not in alignment
right
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no i wouldn't what are what
are your standards okay
that i actually agree with
i
i think if you're a moderate then it
doesn't really matter but if you feel
really strongly left or really strongly
right dating someone that's the polar
opposite of you
is going to be difficult i agreed with
that what are your requirements for a
guy
i mean politically i definitely want us
to have the same view you know i'm a
black woman right so i'm not going to
date like a white republican that would
just be a headache like why would we do
that to ourselves
okay
we wouldn't travel in the same circles
and we don't view this the world the
same way so i wanted to use the world
the same as me and even if you're not
black but you're white and you like get
and understand the black struggle fine
that's fine
um but yeah i definitely want them to
have the same political views as me
because it's just
why bother and having those arguments i
agree with that i agree
okay i'm just gonna turn into a fight
later
yeah no so what like what else
[Music]
well they have to have a car this other
guy who didn't have a vaccine he didn't
have a car i was like how are you coming
to take me out you don't have a car you
know i'm not driving anywhere yeah
i think that's contextual um some guys
live in the city so they don't
need cars i think in la which is where
she's from it's pretty typical to have a
car
um
but yeah i could see that like a car is
a minimum yeah i could that's like a
minimum you have to have a car um i've
also realized that i want someone that
has like some sort of creative or like
job and entertainment like i have
um
you have to be very ambitious because i
am very ambitious i want to be able like
you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night i want us to be able to
come together and talk about all of the
exciting things that happen in each of
our lives right
this
guys just want to be left alone at the
end of the day i'm sorry
what value does that bring a guy
he doesn't want to hear about your day
i'm sorry he'll do it because he loves
you
but that's not
yeah and then the other thing is he has
to be an entertainment
i understand it's a bonus don't get me
wrong
it is a bonus if a guy is an
entertainment for me like that's like in
youtube right because we like people
that are like that are like ourselves so
i'm really high energy and when i meet
people that are on the internet they
typically be they typically tend to be
high energy i understand you wanting
that
but he has to be that you could have a
perfect guy
and if he's not in entertainment no no
no no this other guy was like well i'm
not rich i'm a regular guy and i was
like that's fine but like i'm not a
regular girl
like
i'm i'm not this is what i wanted to say
but you are
you are quite literally a regular girl
like what what is not regular about you
you look average it's okay
girl i don't i think i'm a regular girl
when is why is regular such a bad thing
you can be a normal person
um
but yeah that that is what i was
thinking at this point
so like
if you are gonna date me like either you
have to be able to handle that or you
yourself also have to not be like
regular like i don't think i'm like just
an average person like that is boring
okay so
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
he wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an 8 carat
cushion cut vintage engagement ring if
you make 45 000 a year it would take
what
four years no eight years to afford how
much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you in the
same way did you see my face
bro guys i could not even believe she
said that one
she didn't say
i want it she said i'm getting it from
who from who lady
who is going to give that to you oh my
god
i
that's right i was thinking this woman's
crazy and she's going to end up alone
because
yeah i i should have been a little more
blunt but
understand guys
you're kind of caught off guard and you
don't
hindsight's always 20 20 on what you
should have said
my ring has to sparkle from across the
street like you have to do that [ __ ]
it's good blind people that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right i go to yoga with this girl
who has an eight-carat diamond
engagement ring
company and drives an audi
so it's about more than just that it's
about the fact that are you hotter than
that girl let me see what she looks like
i'm sorry pretty privilege is real it is
like
hotter girls than us
get better things i'm sorry i don't
think i'm a bad looking girl but do i
think
a guy that's a millionaire is gonna
buy me a 200 000 engagement ring oh no
no ma'am no that you can afford that
okay well i'm just thinking like
you're gonna miss out on a lot of guys
because i'm telling you
but not not in a good way not in a good
way i'm telling you like my dad would
but if my mom asked for that from my dad
my dad would have told her to go find a
new boyfriend because there was no way
in hell he was gonna spend two hundred
thousand dollars on an engagement ring
and that's um
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had ten kids my
mom never
he went he said he's built do you hear
do you hear her voice she's saying oh
but he built to that i'm gonna find a
guy that's already that good good luck
let me know when you find him i just
thought i'd take talk of hers recently
and it was like
i'm deleting all dating apps i'm like it
says
respectfully it's you it's not the apps
people meet their signif i don't people
in the manuscript don't like dating apps
it seems like anyway i'm not going to
speak for everyone but people meet their
husbands and wives on there all the time
it's you sis it's you
to the becoming that he wasn't that
originally right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like like to me that's
like such an unwise investment to spend
200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my god no no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
in what world
in what world do you live in
oh this is the crazy thing this is oh my
gosh
i grew up around men that make this kind
of money
like i grew up in that
my last boyfriend made a lot of money
and you're telling me
oh my gosh you tell you're giving me
advice on this stuff oh my god stop stop
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know
this is what i should have said like
lady you are delusional because that's
what i was thinking but i'm i'm kind of
like i sugarcoat stuff i'm sorry i do
yeah like i don't know for me like i
told you like my my
status was going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over the weekend in one weekend
but your status isn't going up you're
just getting older
i'm sorry men value youth it's not a fun
reality that women have to work with
like i don't i don't enjoy the fact
that it's going to get worse from here
that's not a fun reality but that's
that's life
you don't get more options the older you
like i need somebody who can be on that
level right but the problem is like guys
don't care about your money
right
there
i i know but it doesn't like
you know like
i'm just i think you're gonna miss out
on a lot of guys with like this crew
like to me these are like crazy high
standards so
today i listened to my dating coach
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
okay this is what
this is what i was telling torsha on
torch's channel she reacted to this too
you
dating coaches for women there's
an anxious attachment and
basically which is
girls liking guys that don't like them
that's you know in layman's church doing
all this [ __ ] for a guy that doesn't
even like you and when a lot of times
when girls say [ __ ] like that they're
telling you
you know
like sis he doesn't really like you
don't do all this [ __ ] for a guy that
doesn't like you you know do that for a
guy that appreciates it and wants to be
in a relationship with you
um so that's what they mean by minimum
standard okay
what they don't mean
is if i magically say i deserve a 200
000 engagement ring i'm magically gonna
get it
oh my gosh you're not
you're not hot enough for this
prove me wrong you know i i welcome you
to prove me wrong but
it's been like six months
since this video i think and i don't
think she's in a relationship
who is your dating coach married yes and
she has a baby and her wedding ring is
at least five carats yeah
and her man is rich excuse me okay you
know he herself makes like 30 to 50
grand a month coaching women in love
okay but let me i'm gonna go through you
guys
i'm gonna show you guys what this girl
looks like the
i don't know if i have any embarrassing
tabs open so i'm not going to
but i'll just show you on the camera
okay this is what the dating coach looks
like
um
that's her
i hate to say it i'm not trying to be
rude
but sometimes hotter people get
privileges
and then the other girl she talks about
this other girl on the channel like
later i think during this she's like
this hot 120 pound blonde chick
who's really good looking look at hot
people get privileges
it's life
but if you don't have a modeling
contract sorry lady like oh my god i
didn't get a modeling contract
my hotter friends got privileges it just
happens just cause they get it it
doesn't mean you're going to get it
that's life works for you i just like to
me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are going to hear that and be like
no
no no you have to have the man who's
okay with maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
right but what men are willing to
maintain you a 30 year old girl who's
never had a boyfriend
like and why why would they what do they
get out of it
what's in it for them
like
i don't even think i could get that if i
was 21 to be
honest 200k oh no
okay but i'm i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically
want like the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
this is this is what i wish i said
like that that survey that rolo tomasi
always cites where he says
let's says the age that men find the
most attractive
based on dating app data is 21 22 23 24
i think is the highest
so
what
i'm 30 so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't want an age to be wiped off
by somebody who's like in their 40s and
like ready to be serious and start
popping out babies a 21 year old unless
you're kylie jenner is realistically too
young to be like popping out kids
why
that's not historically that's not true
just because we choose to do it at a
later date biologically that is when you
are most ready to pop out kids
i'm not saying that works for everyone
i'm not even saying that you should do
it but the girls that want to do it
are much more likely going to get that
ring like you're too young
yeah i mean that's just i'm sorry the
200 000 like that's crazy to me
that's like
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's crazy
being someone that can make that amount
of money in a shorter period of time
like somebody who would say a musical
artist right a musical producer somebody
who's in entertainment somebody who's on
a tv show somebody who does like
concerts and tours that amount of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i mean
what do you what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like a g
easy right okay
okay g eazy dated hazely
i'm not you might be able to sleep with
him
but g-eazy dated hazely do you look like
hazely
i don't look like hazely
i you you can have sex with a celebrity
but is he gonna marry you is he gonna
wife you that's so different oh my god
150 000 is minimum per show oh wait is
it halsey i don't know how to say your
name i don't know
yeah so if he does a couple shows the
200 grand to him he won't even feel it
no but like this is something coming
from someone like i've been in a
relationship with a guy that was worth
over a million
like i but i would never in a million
years ask him to spend 200k on a ring
that's a crazy thing this girl oh my god
i'm like lady i'm trying to help you
but
i've been in a relationship with a guy
that makes that amount of money
but i'm not entitled to it i don't
deserve his money oh my gosh like to me
that's like that's almost like entitled
like i'm not entitled to his money
i mean
here's the thing if i can afford it
myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like views on like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would even if i had the money i would
never spend that on a ring
but i'm also not that much of a jewelry
person right so it's like you're not
going to need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary or
jewelry all the time like get me my ring
and that's it i don't really need much
else
hi oh gosh
sorry
oh yeah this is this is my thought
i would hope you would need nothing else
i if you spent 200k on a ring don't ask
for presents for a decade i swear to god
because that is more money no
oh no no no
this is la la land nikki i just added
you to it who is that purposely not
putting your camera on
no i have to like connect with the thing
hold on
i've done like a youtube live with her
she's
oh well
sorry
i can i can drop you if this is a bad
time i just thought i'd add you to the
chat
no just real quickly because we got
dinner and lamb and all this other good
stuff listen
this i love this life this is hilarious
this i love you but the girls asking for
300k diamond rings and everything on
this one these guys are now saying that
women hit the wall at age 20. no they
didn't
they have not said that
25 yeah they say that i've seen that
i guess i'm in the wall
it's okay and you're talking about the
they'll be like oh god
but you guys are both women you're both
women so you really don't know
isn't your dating coach a woman
how would she know
no but like being around and seeing just
like a lot of these men they seem like
they're in la la land their styles
and it's like the people that they're
talking about is like who are you
meeting so as
two people are coming with completely
different expectations and like when you
were saying earlier you have pointed out
the person that was in the yoga class
and if you if this is attainable why
haven't you gotten it
why
should if i if i could get a 200 000
engagement ring from like
a guy i want to marry
do you think i would have got it by now
no that's not attainable what the [ __ ]
she had a three hundred thousand dollar
ring the person your coach she has a
three hundred thousand dollar ring it
wasn't like base the reason the ring
that i have i wanted it because of the
fact that growing up
some there's no certain type of thing in
my family that that's what it was but it
wasn't because any of my friends had
that ring i couldn't care less what they
had so no i don't want it because they
have it i know i can have it because
they have it do you understand what i'm
saying like i understand that oh no life
isn't fair
it's not people get things and you don't
get them
that's not
that's not how it works did no one's mom
teach them life's not fair that's what
my mom would always say to me whenever i
felt like something wasn't fair it's
just be like life's not fair
oh
adding 100 000 to thousand dollar eight
carat diamond engagement ring is within
my grasp because i've seen it in real
life
i associate with people who have these
things they're in my circles of people
they're in my well rich people know rich
people so if they're in your circles why
haven't they they set you up with
someone
they're in your circles
friend groups
and i know i can have it because i've
seen it not it's not that i want it
because they have it i want it and then
i've seen it i've seen validation of it
in my in front of my face
well i'm not saying that you you
shouldn't want it because i do know
people that they've dreamt about a
certain type of specific wedding since
they were children i on the other hand i
couldn't kill us
so there was i i definitely understand
that and especially when it does come
time for people to get married where
people like oh why would you spend this
money why i'm like i don't care that's
that person's prerogative that's what
they want that's what they want
but but you're crazy that's
that's insane
if you're saying you see that because of
the fact that you see it on the everyday
person that you communicate with so you
knowing that it's something that's
accessible so if that's that thought
process
okay but
i don't know
i'm just saying like i think you're
looking for like a one percent guy which
is very rare and i think you're gonna
like
like you're gonna overlook a lot of guys
that literally make that amount of money
would like have that money to spend but
choose not to because like you're
looking statistically
oh my gosh statistically
if you find that guy that's willing to
spend that on a ring
but what if he's five nine like oh my
god
their values are to save money
like that's what i'm saying like you
would overlook like my dad in this
situation who's like
top half a percent but your dad also
getting your mom to pop out 10 kids i'm
not trying to hot dog
okay number one
okay i i got cut off here what i was
gonna say is one my mom wanted the kids
my dad probably would have had less of
us sometimes
he low-key says things like he wishes
some of us didn't exist i don't think he
means it like that
but i do would think that
he kind of is tight he's old and like
tired of us you know being at the house
but
i'm like lady what do you have to offer
a man then
everything that you've talked about is
what for you what you want how it's
supposed to go for you everything is not
about you
what does he get out of this he can't
even have as many kids as he wants
oh my goodness
because my dad wanted her to
remember who you're talking about height
so it i didn't even know i thought most
guys won't talk like over six foot
so then when the you know different
people were sharing oh well this is the
percent of these type of i didn't even
know that was the thing because i'm like
most guys i know pretty tall
so now you're adding the height to two
hundred thousand dollar ring but
i don't know girl
i know what the universe knows
well at least your options are open
you're not just trying to just outside
of the hype you're open to dating you
know every not everyone i was just
talking to this guy who doesn't even
have a headboard he has a bed and one
pillow and i said where's your headboard
he goes oh i'm just a regular guy i said
oh
i didn't say i don't want to talk to you
anymore yeah but you said but you said
i'm not a regular girl
but you are oh my gosh
okay so okay so did i misunderstand
you're okay with like not getting that
stuff look at her face she's like no i'm
not
yeah look at the silence like
i just thought like i thought you said
you need the 200k like would you marry
that guy
well i mean this is also the same guy
that doesn't have the vaccine so i
wouldn't even go out with him but
okay what if you found the guy that
makes that amount of money and doesn't
have a vaccine
oh my gosh it's like standards crazy i
do not know many girls that have these
high standards
i really don't
like most of the girls i know want a guy
a little older that makes a little more
money
like it's not crazy like this
um
no here's the thing like the way i see
it in my head is that like by the time i
get there we will be in the place
to afford those things
and you like also you guys like i the
the circles that i run in the people
that i know like i meet very influential
people who can afford those things then
why aren't they dating you
why all the time my everyday life i mean
pearl you saw my apartment like you saw
where i live you know what i mean like i
lived in my free building where you have
to make at least a hundred thousand
dollars a year just to afford to live in
a place where i live
right but i'm saying like to a guy like
money is nothing like men do not care
about your money so if money is nothing
they can afford my 200 000 engagement
ring
no that's that's not what i mean i mean
like money money money gives you no
value
so like i'm not more attractive to a guy
because i make more money
like if anything like they don't prefer
it because they like would prefer
someone with more free time to hang out
with them and like
i'm gonna make a video i saw a comment
that said
this girl was dating like a billionaire
or something or a million
multi-millionaire and
she didn't
enjoy it because he just wanted her to
be ready at the top of the hat and a lot
of these guys that's what it is
especially in like entertainment and
stuff these guys have a lot of free time
they expect you to hang out with them a
lot
so if you got like hobbies and stuff you
put them on the back burner do you want
to do that i know i don't
and that's that's what
people don't understand
so
a lot of times
like
the lower value guy like quote unquote
lower value guy will make you happier oh
gosh sorry guys i think this is
okay it's going again a lot of times the
lower value guy will make you happier
it's not all about money and a lot of
times the manuscript simplifies it down
to money and it's not it takes a certain
type of girl to one date and entertainer
because they're probably going to cheat
on you to be honest
i'm not saying there aren't loyal ones
but
yeah
it happens it's common and two to be
able to give them that type of attention
and time and three
to deal with that lifestyle it's not
easy i've been like my ex-boyfriend had
girls on his dms all the time and it
made me very insecure and it was very
hard i don't think most girls are cut
out for it feel about that i think it's
actually ba
you think that's bs
yes
i rece after seeing the whole thing you
know the podcast that you were on and
seeing that whole drop i'm sorry about
the thing but this is something else
now that a lot of guys are saying that
they want traditional women traditional
women traditional women and then they
don't value the money and other stuff
i've now come up with a theory that the
only reason why they want these
traditional women that do not have money
is so that they can have the ability to
leave these women at will and have them
destitute because especially now with
the whole texas band of the abortion
laws and stuff and seeing these guys are
just like cheering thank god we can have
you barefoot and pregnant back in the
kitchen and not working anymore
i at first i thought that that money
thing didn't really matter but i'm
starting to realize no these guys just
want the ability to leave you high and
dry and then laugh in your face
girl i got
ain't nobody getting pregnant or having
any unwanted babies
okay number one i did not know what this
girl was talking about but
that
god that was that was such like a
butthurt woman response let's let's talk
about the texas abortion law
i don't know specifically what it was
but i'm assuming it's some pro-life law
that that demonstrates an inability to
see from another point of view um my
opinion on like pro-life pro-choice
isn't really relevant to be honest but i
can see from both points of view
pro-life
means that you
you believe that's a child so you think
it's murder so the people that are
parading these laws don't want women to
not have rights they just genuinely
think that it's wrong and it's murder
they think you're killing a life but if
you're pro-choice you don't believe
that's a human you don't think that's
human life so
that's why they pro parade around like
pro-choice they think that it's wrong
that someone else gets to tell them what
to do with their body
um but the pro-life side
sees it as someone else's body they
don't want to leave you high and dry
that's just assuming bad intent and that
really just says more about you than it
does about
anyone else
so i then i'm like trying to figure out
what she's talking about hold on i'll
show you he's crossing my eyes dotted
like my own little uh um what do you
call it new thing that i'm just like
what they really want i don't i don't
think so like because
i don't i don't think so i think like
like
like money just isn't like attractive to
them like they just don't like like when
we see an ambitious like driven man that
turns us on that does not turn a guy on
to like like i think they don't want
like a girl that's like bad with money i
think that's like a turn off i think
that like they don't want a girl you see
her do you see her like pursing her lips
she does not like this she doesn't you
know he doesn't like his terrible
finances whatever but like i just don't
see guys like
being like oh my gosh that's so sexy
she's the ceo like the same way girls
are
like dad
ambition
i said the men that date me are
attracted to my ambition but where is
your boyfriend where is your proof show
me your proof
like you don't
guys this is what i've realized
guys definitely don't want a girl that
just does nothing they want a girl with
hobbies and things that she's passionate
about but
for me i'm kind of a workaholic i have
not found that it helps my dating life
it's just how i am
um i don't think i'm super like
competitive with guys money-wise but i
really am always trying to work hard and
be busy and stuff but it does not help
you dating guys want a guy that's going
to pay attention to them and donate on
them a little bit
like
and the guys that want you to be
ambitious want to live off of you
i would have agreed with you paul until
watching that podcast that you were on
and all these women that they're pushing
these traditional values on that could
barely even formulate a
complete sentence and that's why i
wanted to do the reaction with you on
there because these other girls who are
normally on there and they're like
pushing the whole thing that we don't
care about this we don't care about that
meanwhile these are just only fan girls
that you're trying to push these type of
values on i'm like this whole thing
makes no sense
well well that's the problem she was so
all over the place i was like now we're
talking about only fans homeless fresh
and fit is they just bring on like the
trashiest well because fresh and fit
bring on girls that are free
during the night on a weekday what kind
of
i worked in sales for two years that is
a very different type of girl than the
girls that are on that show and i said
that on the podcast i was like do you
guys think you're in like a little bit
of a bubble
like i was like but i think that doesn't
they see women as though i don't think
they see women as like actual functional
human beings
okay
hello
hi
he was on earlier he said he wanted to
come back on okay i'm gonna stop there
but
yeah this was a
really interesting interview because
i guys i swear to god i have not run
into a lot of girls that are this
delusional i have girls that are
maybe a little bit delusional when it
comes to looks maybe height they think
they're hotter than they are but
i have never
heard a girl in real life before that
moment tell me that she needed a guy
making six figures
um but i did have my epiphany phase at
22. that's what i always say so i kind
of stopped going out and stuff so i
don't know maybe i would know but
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree don't forget to
subscribe and let me know how this audio
sounds i just got a new mic so
your feedback on that would be great
and yeah bye guys